all right the seventh FBI background
check into judge Cavanaugh is finished
it's wrapped and now a confirmation vote
for judge Brett Kavanaugh could come as
early as Saturday President Trump he's
looking forward to this vote Democrats
have been trying to destroy judge Brett
cabinet since
the very first second he was announced
and he was announced for one simple
reason he is an incredible intellect an
incredible person an incredible power
he's been an incredible judge because
they know that judge Kavanagh will
protect uphold and defend the
Constitution of the United States as
written and tonight many US senators
they are on the fence but they
responding positively to today's FBI's
report according to Senator Jeff Flake a
swing vote the FBI's report revealed
zero new evidence against Kavanagh
senator Collins of Maine another crucial
swing vote praised the investigation for
being very thorough here is the bottom
line if both flake and Collins vote in
favor a judge Kavanagh he will be a
Supreme Court justice and today at a
very fiery press conference Senate
Republicans had this to say about the
impending vote and this horrific process
take a look
what we know for sure is the FBI report
did not corroborate any of these
allegations against judge Kavanaugh this
is the 87th day that's three weeks
longer than the average of the last
three or four nominees to the Supreme
Court so don't tell me we haven't spent
enough time what I've been dealing with
since July the 10th the downhill slope
that Schumer has put us on is really
dealing with a demolition derby and
would they just about destroyed a good
person to be on the Supreme Court a vote
against judge Kavanagh tomorrow will be
a confirmation vote for abusing the
confirmation process and a good person
and it will be a vote for the shameful
intimidation tactics that have been
employed as part of an orchestrated
smear campaign this is a
at search-and-destroy mission this is
not a search for the truth and tonight
it is important to remember more
documentation was provided to the Senate
Judiciary Committee than any other
Supreme Court nominee in history and so
far this nomination process is the third
longest in the past 50 years but tonight
the smear merchants on the left are in
full-on freakout mode Senate Democrats
will all demand at an FBI investigation
to be done quickly with limited scope
just last week there now trashing that
very same FBI investigation New Jersey
Senator Bob Menendez he called it a BS
investigation on Twitter now naturally
the whining continued when there's a
television camera in front of these well
publicity-hungry democrats take a look
we Democrats had many fears that this
would be a all too limited process that
would constrain the FBI from getting the
facts having received a thorough
briefing a few minutes ago our fears
have been realized this set of
interviews is at best most charitably
woefully incomplete to put it bluntly it
smacks of a whitewash even a cover-up in
your view is this a fulsome and credible
investigation it's obviously a cover-up
they're making a mockery of the
constitutional requirement that the
Senate provide its advise and consent
that report if it that's an
investigation is a investigation every
one of these Democrats were against
judge Kavanaugh or anybody the president
Trump would have nominated to the court
now in this program while we have
exposed the few the few top echelon and
the FBI that did abuse their power
we have always made a point almost on a
nightly basis to stand up for the rank
and the file
FBI agents field agents you know the
ones that risk their lives like other
law enforcement for us every single day
including those that conducted the
Supplemental background check the FBI
acted in a fair independent manner some
on the left don't like the results the
calls for a more thorough investigation
is beyond observe what is the
be I supposed to do we don't have a
location to investigate no date to
investigate there's no physical evidence
there's no forensic evidence and we
don't even know the day of the week and
every single person the professor Ford
listed to corroborate her story denied
any knowledge of her claims and the one
eyewitness that she listed totally
refuted her claim even a longtime friend
had no idea what she was talking about
they all refuted her claims under
penalty of perjury now twice the other
allegations against Cavanaugh they're
even more shaky the second accused of
making decades old claims that Cavanaugh
had exposed himself at a freshman in
college at a party well she wasn't even
sure that Cavanaugh was the perpetrator
even the New York Times wouldn't publish
her claims and they searched far and
wide for evidence to corroborate her
story they found nothing except that she
had been making calls to other Yale
classmates at the time saying I'm not
sure it's him do you remember
and the third accuser making systematic
drugging gang rape allegations against
teenage girls and her story has changed
many times in about a week she's facing
serious credibility issues and of course
represented by Michael avenatti in a
lawyer of the year
none of these allegations have dates
locations witnesses evidence
corroboration of any kind of any of
these claims so the Democrats really
expect the FBI to magically find
decades-old evidence proving that
Cavanaugh was an evil sexual predator
Systema gang rapist somebody the drugged
teenage girls they really believe the
American people would suspend all
decency all common sense and a belief
that a man with an impeccable 40 year
track record was really secretly a
monster in his youth and did this almost
on a weekly basis and reality this has
always been about politics and power a
delay tactic a transparent attempt to
literally ruin a man's life destroy his
family because they lost an election and
they want the power this has become an
ash
disgrace and in some cases these
political tactics worked Democratic
senator from North Dakota Heidi Heitkamp
by the way now down 11 and the latest
poll claimed to be an independent voice
for the people of North Dakota tonight
we know she's nothing more than a show
for Schumer and the Democratic Party now
I guess she assumes she's not getting
reelected so she's trashing the will of
her own constituents and voting no then
you got Joe Donnelly Indiana also a novo
by the way he's up for re-election in 33
days by the way Indiana voters you can
send him a message and get out and vote
now we're seeing the Democratic Party
play literally their playbook roll out
in full force everything that we have
chronicled on a regular basis on this
show with we now begin our 23rd year on
the Fox News Channel 30 in radio it's
there's now a big crescendo into one of
the most despicable displays than
anything we have ever witnessed and I
warned you they're gonna try and bore
Cavanaugh or whoever the president
picked and then bring back the Clarence
Thomas tactics the smear machine of the
left is in full gear they know no bounds
and some on the left are actually
claiming well okay our allegation it
didn't work let's go after judge
Cavanaugh's temperament that might be
disqualified you're saying he was just
too aggressive when defending himself
against false allegations of drugging
and gang raping teenage girls ask
yourself this question okay how would
you react if you were falsely accused of
rape of drugging teenage girls happened
almost on a every other every weekend
basis gang raping them boys lining up in
the halls how would you react what is
the appropriate reaction
how would your reactive senators were on
national TV calling you evil comparing
you to Bill Cosby suggesting that you're
guilty of serious crimes you never
committed far left retired Justice John
Paul Stevens weighing in well this
should disqualify him from becoming a
justice this is the same radical former
Supreme Court justice
who doesn't believe in the Constitution
he once demanded the Second Amendment be
repealed and wrote that the election of
george w bush violated our constitution
and just moments ago judge Cavanaugh in
an op-ed just released for The Wall
Street Journal he eloquently defended
himself on the eve of what will be a
historic vote this is a tipping point
for this country he talked about these
ridiculous allegations he wrote quote
after all those meetings and after my
initial hearing concluded I was
subjected to wrongful sometimes vicious
allegations my time in high school in
college more than 30 years ago has been
ridiculously distorted my wife my
daughters have faced vile and violent
threats and against that backdrop I
testified before the Judiciary Committee
last Thursday to defend my family my
good name my lifetime of public service
my hearing testimony was forceful and
passionate that is because I forcefully
and passionately denied the allegations
against me
he continued yeah I was very emotional
last Thursday
more so than I've ever been I might have
been too emotional at times well I know
that my tone was sharp I said a few
things I should not have said he did
apologize once in the hearings I hope
everyone can understand that I was there
as a son a husband a dad and I testified
with five people foremost in my mind my
mom my dad my wife and most of all my
two daughters now sadly this kind of
common sense and logic and decency from
Judge Cavanaugh it means nothing to the
left how would you respond by the way it
means nothing to their cohorts their
friends in the mainstream media you got
all the people on the left whining
crying complaining those that believe in
guilt by accusation just doing what they
do best today
feigning outrage by the way when did any
of these people on the Judiciary
Committee the snowflakes in the floor of
the Senate being taken out all day they
have a protest Bill Clinton like this
they ever stand up for Juanita Broderick
Kathleen Willey
Paula Jones
that's right Diane Feinstein who
recommended Deborah cats whatever cats
didn't believe Paula Jones it was only
10 or 12 minutes
so you have a lot of hypocrisy feign
selective moral outrage and today you
have far left protestors erupting all
over Capitol Hill and as you can imagine
emotions were running high logic was
running very low
we even sent our own Grif Jenkins down
to the middle of all this in the middle
of the mob asking these people what they
thought about due process the
presumption of innocence the rule of law
the answers will stun you take a look
this is a job interview there's no
presumption of innocence in a job
interview do you believe that he was
given a fair chance at his confirmation
fair chance this man is sitting amongst
friends of his about what they need and
what they deserve rich white man who
doesn't give a about us in my view judge
Kavanagh made it pretty clear that he
does not have the judicial temperament
he believes the Supreme Court is just
one more political football that's not
what the Supreme Court is about and I
think in that hearing judge Cavanaugh
disqualified himself no presumption of
innocence no due process well let me
tell you if that's the case there's no
country there's no Constitution it's sad
it's shocking and it's frankly beyond
chilling coming up we're gonna have a
lot more of Gryff including his full
interview with Senator Elizabeth Warren
now today she led this horde of
demonstrators demanding that Cavanaugh's
life and reputation continue to be
destroyed without these fundamental
beliefs that we as Americans should all
share regardless of political
orientation you have to have some
corroboration there's got to be some
evidence some presumption of innocence
only good news tonight is the left
well they've officially been exposed to
the American people see those protesters
you're looking at the modern radical
left Democratic Party and the media the
party of double standards the party of
smears lies character assassination
family bludgeon
with no plans to offer the hard-working
law-abiding taxpaying citizens you the
American people who make this country
the single greatest best last great hope
for man on this earth look what they do
the people that's not the people of this
country that is one party though sadly
that has abandoned any sense of
fundamental decency fairness and common
sense now thankfully you the American
people it is now awoken a lot of people
in this country look at this Rasmussen
poll on President Trump
it's his highest approval rating ever
according to an NPR poll of all places
remember the Democratic enthusiasm blue
wave edge that they had it's totally
evaporated today at this hour we're
seeing the chaos the mayhem the madness
the insanity we got the leaders of the
Democratic Party a full-on assault on
the integrity of the FBI they've so
convinced their party activists about
guilt upon accusation that that's fine
in America no due process is fine in
America no presumption of innocence is
fine how does that work for you and your
family in your life slander smear
character assassination that's one party
in America today great job
Dianne Feinstein Chuckie Schumer Nancy
Pelosi Maxine Waters do you want them in
power in 33 days now the American people
now the people that they're leading
causing the pandemonium in our nation's
capital because their so-called leaders
convince them that guilt by accusation
is okay that that defining somebody has
a rapist a gang rapist a drug or of
teenage girls without cooperation in
America is okay well those are the
tactics of today's radical Democratic
Party this is why for years I appointed
this out on the show this happens every
two and four years and now with every
Supreme Court appointment nearly every
one they disseminated salacious lies
about President Trump before and after
the election they advanced bizarre
conspiracy theories that one candidate
actually paid for hookers urinating in
beds they talk about it as if it's truth
they disseminate it as propaganda
for elections they do it to to start up
you know witch-hunt invent
investigations and conspiracies they
call people racist sexist misogynist
homophobic xenophobic Islamophobic
that's it Republicans conservatives want
dirty air and water we drink the water
and breathe the air they want children
to die well if you're only gonna raise
Medicare 7% a year that means you want
to throw your own grandmother off the
cliff we hear it every two and four
years and when these vile accusations of
drugging gang raping teenage girls
without evidence that's that's not to be
believed by the FBI these are the
consequences that's the reaction is this
the party you want in power you want to
elect these people in 33 days look at
your screen high drama tonight with
these four senators they appear to hold
the keys to the Cavanaugh vote are they
gonna give in to this new America of
guilt by accusation lying smearing
slander character bludgeoning of the
last 17 days forget the last 40 years of
this man's life no corroboration are
they gonna give in to this has any of
this had any impact on those four
senators do they believe in the
presumption of innocence that's their
question tonight do they believe and due
process the rule of law do they have
common sense and decency do they believe
that you've got to have some
corroboration do they believe in our
great Constitution or are they going to
reward forever the slanderous tactics of
the hard left that only want power